this is Lapland in Sweden's far north
lots of nature very few people and peace
and quiet except in Gary Vova at the
Santa Winter Games the big day kicks off
with a parade through this small town
and I'm right in the middle of it all
Christina shower is next to me with her
daughter we are representing Germany
together Christina and I have just met
she's lived in Norway for many years and
often appears there as a female Santa
Claus but we don't have much time to
discuss strategy give me any tips for
the Santa Winter Games
well the Asians are considerably younger
so they'll be faster and yes we have to
obey the rules you're right one of the
events is dancing to Christmas music
we're hoping to Rekha points with a
polished performance the three of us
come up with a routine in record time
back at the gates the crowd is gathering
on a square in the center of town
anxiously awaiting Santa's from around
the world I'm very nervous
unlike Christina who's a regular here
the first event is lassoing
reindeer theoretically at any rate team
Sweden goes first
pay close attention and then just do
what they do close but not quite there
sadly all of Christina's four attempts
fail but team Hong Kong manages three
successful tosses probably due to the
fact that the centre Apple did a secret
practice session
we continue on to the next event without
a break delivering presents or rather
raw eggs have to carry the sack on your
back it's much too dangerous on the sled
and I think it will be difficult in the
chimney team France goes first followed
by Hong Kong and China because I can't
ski christine has to compete then I take
my turn on the sled apparently
completely forgetting my own advice but
all our eggs arrive under the tree
intact and we get bonus points for a
bold climb up the narrow chimney what do
you think it went pretty well
we got it done at least I'm optimistic
about our chances because now it's time
to dance
there are bonus points for those who get
the spectators to dance along with him
[Music]
but Christina and I are so focused on
our choreography that we forget about
the possible bonus the current standings
have us in fourth place
[Music]
and finally the grand finale with three
events a porridge eating contest is one
of them but more importantly now I can
finally put the secret contents of my
suitcase to use the final event is
Christmas tree decorating and we simply
have to win that
I was lucky to be paired with Christina
who really goes for it in the events
where our death probably fails after the
porridge eating contest we move on to
wrapping presents tied up with a bow of
course and now we come to decorating the
tree along with the glass topper
I've also brought traditional handmade
wooden ornaments from Germany's our
mountains and of course big glass
bubbles no one can be dead right hey
we've done a great job then
the jury deliberates the final bonus
points are awarded for the best tree
[Applause]
it fits in my heart who it is I'm be I'm
being so glad for this well the first
Swedish Santa betweens this ever so we
couldn't be more happy than well
my disappointment at our fourth-place
finished disappears in the cozy warmth
of a campfire and I've certainly learned
a lot the day draws to close with a
group sleigh ride accompanied by the
Chinese version of Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer